one of the most interesting things I
think about this is how businesses are
finally coming around so you were on the
front end of doing this personally and I
see a lot of people doing that now but
actually businesses are becoming green
and they're becoming aware that people
want this are there how do you when
you're shopping and you know not just
for food but for whatever how do you
sort of mitigate figuring out what's
doing good work what companies are being
responsible and all that well you guys
are deep into that into rewarding good
companies and good behavior and I think
that's great
riot that they're doing that and
something I've been interested in for
years a lot of businesses have figured
out what we started to see at the late
80s or early 90s there was a company
called northern telecom Nortel northern
telecom they made more than half the
switching equipment back then for AT&T
and part of their process to clean their
circuit boards they use CFCs but the
head of the company back then in 1989
whatever started to hear about ozone
depletion went from the top on down all
my middle management people all the
executives like me down the janitor
we're gonna find some way to stop using
CFCs and we're gonna do that because
it's the right thing to do I don't care
what it cost I'll take a haircut with my
salary yeah I said and amend it they
found there was a way to do with citrus
to clean the circuit boards with citrus
or something or some other substance and
they the circuit boards work just fine
they didn't have a diminished product
because of it and he met with the CFO
after a year or so doing he said tell me
the bad news now that I've mouthed off
and done this how much is this cost us
we saved $250,000 yeah well that was a
kind of a wake up call late 80s early
90s but wait a minute they did the right
thing and they save money there's lots
of that out there occasionally people
are doing it and it cost them that
happens on occasion
sometimes it's revenue neutral but the
vast majority of the time that I've seen
that people did the right thing
certainly with new buildings when
businesses are moving into remodeling or
building a new building they realize the
savings nowadays because building a new
building or even a house as I'm doing a
LEED Platinum home it's like an iceberg
the kind of iceberg where there's a
little tiny piece above the water just a
little triangle above the water the vast
amount of that iceberg is below the
water that's the cost of running the
building over time over it's men
many years of use that little piece at
the top is a cost to building it that's
a little chunk it looks massive at the
time right you're standing on it there
you know waiting for rescue it looks
really big that number that it cost to
do a remodel or to build from the ground
up but over the life of it it's it's a
huge number and people who are in it for
the long haul and many businesses are
looking long-term they used to just look
at the the quarterly dividend but what's
the quarterly number I don't want to get
fired I don't want the board to get on
my ass what can I do to show a good
quarterly return they're looking beyond
that and telling the board we got to be
good corporate citizens and for the
long-term health of this company because
guess what I'm having a psychic moment
now energy prices are gonna go out you
know and they're still gonna go out
they're still gonna go out just buying
some energy-efficient lighting and an
energy-saving thermostat for your
mom-and-pop store and some weather
stripping or little stuff you're gonna
get a payback on that stuff right away
so I know a lot of people will say and I
think you're addressing this already but
a lot of people say well it's easy it's
easy for you and you've got more money
you can do it but you're saying there
are ways to do this and haven't they
shown that when companies do some of
these changes people are willing to pay
a little bit more that that social
responsibility has become part of all
these business plans right many people
are with many companies you have to do
this stuff because of you know it's it's
the right thing to do III really think
and the return is there people are gonna
feel good about it over time people are
going to understand and when people say
to me the most important point I want to
make is when people say to me and I
can't afford a Nissan Leaf like you have
today I can't afford you know solar
panels like you have a six kilowatt
system and I say neither could I when I
started when I started in 1970 it was
very expensive to buy solar panels so I
didn't do that took me 20 years to buy
solar electric two decades but I did the
cheap and easy stuff and I save money
the electric car I bought 1970 was not
expensive like a Nissan Leaf or a Tesla
I couldn't afford a Tesla today I could
afford a leaf but this is pretty cool
though it's a very foolhardy cause I get
another series or something I'm buying
one but people who say they can't do it
the way I do it
agreed I couldn't either when I started
you don't run up Mount Everest you get
the base camp you get acclimated and
adjust and you see how high you can
climb some people aren't going to make
it to the summit some
people are never gonna be able to afford
solar electric but can you buy some
light bulbs to lower your energy bill
put money in your pocket right away
mm-hmm you know energy-saving thermostat
weather stripping bike riding when
weather and fitness permit public
transportation in defense avail
available near you home gardening home
composting all that stuff is dirt cheap
do that stuff and you're gonna see money
back right away I like the finish on
that segment what are you guys doing to
save some money and do something good
for the environment let us know in the
comments right down below